And everybody I just want to make this video to go over our, so I went over our home page
and stuff of our members site, but now I want to talk about just our courses, so the courses.
So on the courses, so the course home page is is basically, let's say I think this is the home page.
This is the kind of the landing page that you can see that go from our website that the people can go on here and click on here to order our course.
Then they'll go to, if they do click to order the course, then they'll go to the purchase page, which is this page, which is as purchase to stop fighting cancer, start treating the cause course.
So this is how they purchase it that they pay the paypal.
So $297 is the cost of the course now, we've added so much information that I'm tempted to charge more, but that's what it is right now.
Then they'll get a thank you, this will be the page, you're obviously looking at the back office, that's why you can see all these things.
Thank you for your purchase will receive an email shortly with a link, blah, blah, blah.
Then they can go to the course itself and look at all the different pages of the course.
These are all the pages of the course so far, the different modules in the different modules, they'll see each module.
So this is module one, the bandaid approach, they can see all these other modules so they can click on them. So it is not a course that they have to do one, then two, then three, it's not a course like schoolwork like that, they could just jump to module seven or module four or whatever, right.
So actually this video is going to change that.
And then they'll be able to see, watch the little intro video, and then they'll be able to watch some other videos on there, how I got into cancer and all like that.
And from there they could jump to the next modules, but I, what I wanted to show you is these different modules and what we are offering on these modules. So this is like module two is called the Connor's method.
And I created a little video for each one of these modules, like this is a 12 minute video on this module, you can download the transcript, but then also what we sound in our store is this hour and a half long video called the Connor's method.
And it's free, it's a free download for the course, so what they would have had to pay $30 for it's free of the course.
And all the pages, they can link to our home website, if they want to become a patient could pretty sure that we will actually get a lot of patients on the country, see this course.
So this is not going to slow our.
Our crazy to stone, unfortunately, I will probably speed it up, module two is on that's module two that's what we just did module three then gets into more details, finding the cause again I created a little video at each one of these they could download the transcript this video is a little bit longer 25 minutes.
They could download the book from here free link to a whole bunch of pages on our website about causes of these have to do bio toxins of toxins and a whole bunch of information on our website and other video that I talk about treating the cause that I was interviewed by somebody.
And then we get into module four with.
Addressing the cancer so addressing the cancer short call minute video, this is where we get into protocols so here's need a protocol and a video about protocols and then.
Dustin has to create a link or have to create a link to the protocol page from here so i'll create a link to the protocol page from here.
And then these are the protocols so the main protocol page is.
Cancer protocols so here's the main protocol page personalize protocols for specific cancers.
Breast cancer brain cancers upper GI cancers in all of these cancers okay so these are all the different cancers that have protocols so they could click on this breast cancer page.
And this is what they would go to so if they clicked on the.
The breast cancer page they go to this page and then it lists has a video about breast cancer itself explains a little bit about the different breast cancers, just like on our website but then it gets into more specific protocols.
Like a basic ductile carcinoma here's supplement protocol turkey tail complete this leaks them to the store so they could buy these products right from our store.
Basic lobular links them to the products on the store, inflammatory breast cancer links them to products on the store triple negative links them products of the store and other all the pages have this other cool more abilities we do they have a digestion they have.
Information they have constipation they have you know links them to things on the store.
So that's what each one of the pages looked like so all the different protocol pages have multiple different cancers let's say the upper GI cancers have you know.
stomach and pancreatic and things like that lower GI would be colorectal things like that so there's four or five or six different cancers in each page and there's one 12 or 13 different pages so we got 50 different cancers listed with protocols in there, which that's all pretty nice for 300 bucks that they're getting.
Then on top of that then you that was module four then you want to module five that's where we talked about the right machine and I have a video it's about 17 minutes long explaining why right machine but that it says buy it to right machine with doctor cutters unique programming here this links to the store and the page of the store that it links to is.
The right page of the store so this page right here.
This is what it links to program right machine.
The hamburger the census product is not available for normal retail purchases only available to those and we specifically offer this package following the case review or those on our stock fighting cancer education of course.
purchase this we will need to call and confer details and acceptance for purchase was we need to follow and ask if you want to have cancer you can.
So that's how that coverage is going to program it oh yeah colorectal cancer alright that's your program it for you or that we want to get the details on that person.
We'll talk a little bit more on a staff meeting about this but if we have people from the store that are going to purchase a right one other step that would be nice to have is to create a file for them in practice fusion because we had a file for them in practice usually to track it in that way.
Because even though they're not patient it still gives us they did purchase you know bigger equipment for the so we'll talk about that.
So that's the module five has a whole bunch of other videos on the right and understanding frequencies and that video that I shared on the signal platform on can I buy a program right is on here.
And then another link at the bottom to buy the program to raise.
Then module six is on is clean up the environment again I have a video on that and this is where we push people to the genetic review so consider a genetic review.
What we need from you what you receive from us this explains the genetic review that they'll have a link to the good zoom call and they can order the genetic review right here from there they would be pushed to this page on the website which is this one right here it's $1,000 genetic review.
So this explains it again the solely available those are patient members have already in a case review or members of the stop finding kids of course.
And then.
And then module seven is what we get into the spiritual aspects of it and share download of the book and video right there.
We got a lot of that book.
So you made part of this is seven modules and then you got all the cancer protocols and which there is a lot of them and the ability to purchase the genetic.
Only plan and the ability to purchase the right only plan right directly from there.
So I just think it's going to be great. And here's the stuff that this is that that has the introduction and that has the different modules on it how to start each monitor.
So that's all right hopefully that was good introduction to this course and you could push people to the course just even from our website now so on our website on any one of the pages you'll see this up here courses books blog videos store begin here.
So all you have to do is tell people oh well just go to the go to our website and click courses and then this is the course page that I showed you.
So right from here they can buy that next thing that we're going to do that which will do get them July hopefully is this and then we're going to have a specific course on genetics and cancer.
And then we're going to have a course on line and we're going to have a course on about two different step.
Of course that how to make courses that will be the next question.
So this will be a nice little addition that will be helpful to carry out to our country.
Hopefully it's a pressure off some things.
So hopefully that helps and bye.